la vie est un des ennemis est scooté
dans ces cas là est autant laisser
parler un expert moscou lors de ces
amateurs il ya quelqu'un sur ce plateau
qui est payé pour ça
allez-y non mais moi je vais raconter
comment je racontais ma femme c'est ça
j'étais jeune journaliste alice le bic a
annoncé l orée des cigarettes et
audoises hôtesses gosses dont il fut
mellick eu la gueule et du cou
là il chauffe et on voulait vous qui lui
les portes à frazer
et voilà je suis tombé à vous j'ai eu un
flash tombe amoureux d'elle tout de
suite j'ai habité à paris il
raccompagnée en voiture d'un ancien à
paris et je suis plus jamais retourner à
nancy ils m'ont appelé le lendemain au
boulot énorme été ou qui je suis à paris
quand as tu reviens je ne reviendrai pas
il te reste l'appareil qu'est-ce qui se
masque élevé en fût pas la télé
[Applaudissements]